ظل امريكا. فهم يرون ان العقوبات
يمكن ان تخرجهم من الوضع الحالي.
والارهاق. الفيروس ينتشر بسرعة
فائقة والبنية التحتية هشة
كوريا الجنوبية وجدت الفرصة
لتسخر من بلاد كيم منتهزة فرصتها
عليه ان يسلمه للمطاعم المركزية
والتي تتبع حكومة كوريا
هي اجابتكم انتم ايضا متابعين
حول هذا السؤال. هل سينفذ كيم
ضربته الموعودة تجاه الولايات
المتحدة كما قالها سابقا ام انه
صواريخه النووية وكانه يقول ها
هي وريثة العرش تتفقد ما سيورثه
الرد بسرعة خاطفة. لا احد يقايض
مصيره بكعكة ذرة. فمن الافضل ان
وازمة فيروس كورونا ظهر هاكيم
بوجه تكسوه تجاعيد الحزن
التصريحات كان كيم قد حضر لتجربة
اطلاق صاروخ واسونج سبعة عشر
شخصية قوية. تمتاز بتصريحاتها
اللاذعة. فقد تذوق رئيس كوريا
هو امتلاك اعظم قوة نووية في
العالم. اسبوعان قبل هذه
وجه امريكا قائلة ان المشككين في
قدرات صواريخ كوريا الشمالية
سيعلمون قريبا ما يمكن ان تفعله
تلك الصواريخ. وبلادنا لا تخشى
العاصفة وينتصر كيم على الفيروس.
شقيقة الزعيم لا تلعب. للجنون
الشمالية. الهدف توفير اللحوم
ومواجهة الازمة الاقتصادية
يكن وحيدا في تجربة هذا الصاروخ
المراد. وعلى غير العادة ها هو
بينما زعيم كوريا الشمالية
يعلنها صريحة هدف بلادي النهائي
مرضه لتنتشر اشاعة وفاته. ظهرت
في الواجهة لادارة البلاد وكانت
العقوبات هكذا قالتها كيم يو
جون. عندما غاب شقيقها ليصارع
رأيت المجنون وبيده حجر فلتنفذ
بجلدك هاربا لتنجو بحياتك. فما
للرد باذلال كوريا الشمالية في
ذروة ازمتها الاقتصادية. وبعرض
الجنوبية بعضا منها. انهم لا
يعرفون العيش في راحة وامان في
العام للامم المتحدة. كوريا
الشمالية تتجاهل قرارات مجلس
بالكم اذا كان بيد هذا المجنون
سلاح نووي ينهي دولا ويدفن
يعلن عن تجربة نووية جديدة. كيم
متهور هذا ما استطاعت امريكا
تغلق فمك يا غبي. هذا كان ردها.
من طرق الباب ياتيه الجواب. فما
سخي من رئيس كوريا الجنوبية
يونسوكيول. ها هو يعرض المساعدة
امريكا والجارة الجنوبية تندد.
لتتجه الولايات المتحدة لفتح باب
الكاميرا الخفية. وعلى فتاة تاتي
من خلفه لتضع القماشة على وجهه.
الساخرة. هنا مجلس الامن يمطر
كيم بالعقوبات الواحدة تلو
والضحايا يتساقطون بالمئات.
الجميع في حالة حظر ولا احد يجرؤ
الاقتصادية لها مقابل تخلي
بيونغيانغ عن الاسلحة النووية.
الصاروخية. تجاهل الخارج والداخل
والشرق والغرب ليعلنها الامين
الخانقة. الكثير من الخبراء
الاقتصاديين سقوط كيم. امريكا
فكل ما حدث هو بتخطيطها لانها
المستشار الاقرب لكيم. ها هي في
المرأة الحديدية بجدارة لتصبح
اكثر النساء الكوريتين شراسة.
وسبعة عشر. وفي وضح النهار وامام
الجميع وتحت ستار برنامج
المتحدة وقت قياسي. هكذا وصف كيم
الصاروخ وسونج سبعة عشر. كيم لم
حضارات بضغطة زر. الريق الامريكي
يجف عندما يلقي كيم كلمته او
فنون وشقيقة المجنون لابد ان
تكون اكثر جنونا. انتزعت لقب
على مخالفة اوامر كيم. ليوجه
بهذا الامر العاجل من يمتلك كلبا
الاخيرة بعملية اغتيال مدبرة.
نعم كيم بات زعيما وحده ليحكم
جماحه قيادة كوريا الشمالية. وان
يكون اقوى رجل فيها بل اراد ان
استراتيجي في العالم قادر على
الوصول الى اراضي الولايات
على الخارج وساعيا الى تنفيذ
اصلاحات اقتصادية. ورغم حجمه
كيم يظهر للعالم ابنته ليحتفل
بعيد ميلادها من امام منصة
الامريكية باستخدام السلاح
النووي. نعم. هو اقوى سلاح
المرأة الحديدية بجدارة لتصبح
احدى اقوى نساء الكوريتين شراسة.
المحادثات مع كيم والهدف نزع
سلاحه النووي. ليس بهذه السهولة
لها والدها لتكمل مسيرته. ولكن
مهلان انسيتم الازمة العالمية
والغربية تنهال عليه من كل جانب.
لم يعرهم اي اهتمام ليكمل كيم
كان الجميع يضحك والكاميرا تصور
ولم يعلم انه يطلق انفاسه
محبوبة. ليثبت براءته وبلمسة
هوليودية. وبدخول مفاجئ ها هو
مدريد.
الدولة الاكثر عزلة في العالم
لتصبح رعبا. طموح كيم لم تكبح
ليطفئوا فتيل العقوبات. ويشتاط
الامريكان والجيران غضبا. اذا
ليقول عبارته الشهيرة بضغطة زر
سينتهي كل شيء. نعم سرق النوم من
باصداراتها المتجددة والتي تفوق
اصدارات هواتف ابل وجالاكسي.
تعرض المساعدة لتكسب ود الزعيم
الكوري لكن كيم قال لا لتمر
الاخرى ليقف هنا الاصدقاء
والحلفاء ونقصد هنا الصين وروسيا
الامن من خلال مواصلة تطوير
برنامجها للاسلحة النبوية.
يا ابناء العم سهام. كيم يرمقكم
بنظرته الحادة وابتسامته
يكون الاقوى عالميا. بعد
تحركاتهم. العقوبات الامريكية
طريقه حتى اصبحت امريكا تخاف.
فقد انطلق ليطور منظومته
التي ساعدت شقيقها في قتل اخيهم
الاكبر كيم جونغ نام وبطريقة عجز
حياته عزيزا او غاليا. قتل شقيقه
بدم بارد. وعند اتهامه بالحب قتل
الشيطان عن التذكير بها في
الثالثة عشر من فبراير الفين
مثلما كان هتلر شغوفا بالرسم.
فقد درس في سويسرا برفقة شقيقته
يجمد الدم في عروق امريكا.
مستعرضا صواريخه النووية
البالستي العابر للقارات. مع
تعهد بمواجهة تهديدات نووية
وبحركة بسيطة. ها هم يرفعون
ايديهم في مجلس الامن حق الفيتو
السمين وقصر قامته فان كيم جونغ
كان شغوفا برياضة كرة السلة
بداية خاطفة وانطلاقة حاسمة.
واصغر اخوته تولى مقاليد الحكم
كيم يو جونغ التي تجمعه بها
علاقة وثيقة واستثنائية. كيميو
خلفا لوالده عام الفين واحد عشر.
وفي بداية حكمه كان يبدو منفتحا
اعين جيرانه وازعجهم بتجاربه
المرعبة. يقال ان خلف كل رجل
عظيم امرأة ومن يق خلف كيم هي
شقيقته الصغرى والتي انتزعت لقب
ليس بينك وبين الاعدام سوى ان
تقول لا. فان قلتها فقد اخترت
الموت. وقد تجد نفسك امام فوهة
مدفع او قد تجد نفسك عاريا.
بحرارة ولتبكي. وان لم تستطع
البكاء فلتتباكى فانت في حضرة
احشاءها. وان كنت عزيزا سيعطيك
كوبا من السم. لا يوجد في قاموس
بجانب كلاب لم تتذوق اللحم
لاسابيع. لتكون انت من سيسكن
كيم. نحن لا نهول. شاهدوا هذه
المشاهد كي تلتمسوا صدق كلامنا.
سيتراجع عن تصريحاته السابقة?